This is a download from BBC Learning English to find out more, visit our website.
6-Mute English from BBCLearningEnglish.com
Hello and welcome to 6 Minute English, I'm Dan and I'm Rob.
So Dan, what's a- oh, sorry.
Oh it's my wife.
Hang on.
You didn't answer.
Well, don't take this personally, Dan, but I'm not exactly crazy about someone
eavesdropping on my phone call.
If you eavesdrop on something, you secretly listen to someone's conversation.
Something's a private, you know.
Oh, of course, I totally understand.
One quick question for you, though.
Do you have a smart speaker, you know, like Google Assistant,
Amazon's Alexa, or Apple's Siri?
Ah sure, yes, I've got one.
It's great.
I can ask it all sorts of questions.
It tells me about the news and whether it plays music, when I want, it does all sorts.
You just give it a voice command and it does what you want.
So it can hear you, can it?
Of course.
How else can you give it a voice command all the time?
Well, I assume so.
So how do you know it's not eavesdropping on you?
Well, I, uh, oh, I see.
I hadn't thought of that.
Well, that's our topic for this 6 Minute English.
How safe is your smart speaker?
However, before that, here is our quiz question.
By what percentage the number of smart speakers used in US households increased
from December 2017 to December 2018?
Is it a around 40%, b around 60% or c around 80%.
Oh, well, I know they are very popular even in my household.
So I'm going to go for c around 80%.
Well, we'll find out if you're right later in the program.
So smart speakers and privacy.
Florian Schalb is an assistant professor at the University of Michigan School of Information.
Here he is speaking on the BBC World Service Program,
the wife factor about smart speakers.
What does he say people are introducing into their homes?
You're basically introducing listening bug in your home in your most intimate space.
While the companies say they're only actively listened to what's going on in your home
when they hear the keyword, the microphone is still on the whole time in order to be able to
detect that keyword. We don't know to what extent companies are cooperating with the government
or to what extent the government might try to circumvent companies' security mechanisms
in order to then be able to listen to what you're doing.
So what did he say people are introducing, Rob?
He basically said we're introducing a listening bug.
Now a bug is a small electronic device used for secretly listening to conversations,
much like a spy would use.
Yes, and he mentioned it was in our most intimate space.
Intimate means private and personal.
Well I can't think of anywhere more intimate than my home. Indeed.
He also said that the smart speakers' microphone is on the whole time,
even though the companies insist that they're only actively listening when the keyword is said.
Yes, he suggested that we can't know how far a company might be cooperating with a government
to eavesdrop on people or whether a government might be circumventing a smart speaker's
security and listening in any way without the company or owner's permission.
Circumvent means cleverly bypass or go round.
So if all this eavesdropping is possible, why are smart speakers so popular?
Good question. And here's Florian Schalber again with an answer.
He conducted a study on people's attitudes to privacy when it came to smart speakers.
How do people feel about having a smart speaker that could eavesdrop on them?
What we often saw as people just being resigned to this is the tradeoff they have to make
if they want to enjoy the convenience that a smart speaker provides to them.
He said that people are resigned to the privacy tradeoff.
If you're resigned to something, you accept something unpleasant that can't be changed.
Yes, and a tradeoff is a compromise.
You accept something bad to also receive something good.
So people accept that a smart speaker gives them advantages, even though there could be
downsides. Yes. In the grand scheme of things, the data that these devices here is probably not
that significant considering all the data companies have about us already anyway.
So can I have the answer to the quiz then? Of course.
Earlier I asked by what percentage the number of smart speakers used in US households
increased from December 2017 to December 2018. Was it A, around 40%, B, around 60%, or C,
around 80%. What did you say, Rob? I said C, around 80%. And you are right.
C, the answer is around 80%. From 66 million in December 2017 to 118 million in December 2018,
and around 10 million people in the UK now use one too. I guess they're not worried about eavesdrops.
Nice slide into the vocabulary there, Dan. If someone eavesdrops on you, it means they secretly
listen to your conversation. They could be eavesdropping on you through a bug, which is a small
electronic device used to secretly listen to conversations. Yes, they may have bugged your most
intimate or private and personal spaces. Next we had circumvent. If you circumvent something,
such as security, you cleverly bypass it or go around it. Then we had resigned. If you are
resigned to something, it means you accept something unpleasant that can't be changed. And lastly,
we had trade-off. A trade-off is a compromise. You get something good, but you also get something
bad. Right, like six minutes English, a great discussion and vocabulary, but the trade-off is
it only lasts six minutes, which is just about now actually time to go. So until next time,
find us all over the place online and on social media. Just search for BBC Learning English.
Bye for now. Goodbye.